i even tell you about my friend who uh
who pull he's a he's a larger black man
okay
and he says when he takes a piss
sometimes
and he looks down on his dick he's got a
regular dick ah it's a bubble he he
he it ruined his whole day he told us
that when like he goes
i look at my dick sometimes and i just
go [ __ ]
then he told me an amazing story about
how
he stepped off a curb and a car
hit like a van was so close that it
actually
burned hit the end of his nose oh damn i
don't believe it
yeah go okay assume no true story and he
went
[ __ ] so was the side man i don't know
think about it brian this was the
sidebar he probably stepped off
after it went also there's the back end
so
so he's he's i don't call it and then i
don't know but i don't know but just
talk logistics you almost got it because
it's not fast and furious seven
so it i don't like the mirror sticks out
right like the mystic
so the mirror would have went like this
and then you were like whoa crazy in the
car all right so maybe
it never happened but carry on yeah
never happened you almost got killed by
a fan my grandpa killed a knot now i
don't know that story
you know and i don't like you you know
when i was driving i went ah that never
happened did it i just i'm 37 realized
grab a lot it's almost happened to me in
seattle i was on my phone stepped off
and almost got killed
but did you did it did it skin your nose
well i mean in other words it was that
close he said he could feel the air on
his nose
so it skins your nose though not mine
his oh okay
and then remember that time when i
watched it i might have added that there
it is
remember i almost got hit by a car yeah
i do remember that oh
was it close i still go like this wasn't
that close i don't know it was kind of
close
it was from me to cat no that's not true
it was that's absolutely and
i walked like this no no you were very
[ __ ] close
okay karen so your friend i saved your
life you did
now he i don't know why i'm telling you
the story but he
he went oof holy [ __ ] right holy [ __ ]
goes to take a piss all set to be upset
about his dick
and faints and died he fainted because
please tell me he died it was like a
reflective delay of realizing he almost
died
no he didn't die but then he went
through the bathroom there we go there
he ran his legs over and it was mr t in
there
and it was mr t i knew it so
so you guys figure that out so my
takeaway from this is the blackout
i like i like your detective work
because i
not the movies i was told that story i
know but now that you say the mirror you
got to keep the mirror in mind
yeah think of the side mirrors that'd be
the first thing i'm going to probably
kill you going fast enough
right rip off if it gives it's gonna
[ __ ] you up if it gives [ __ ] you up
but that was all they always fold in
right so it's probably gonna fold in
yeah well on instagram there was a
[ __ ] guy on a motorcycle i don't
thought that did you see that on the car
gets hit by a van
and and then they kind of skid off like
this
and the motorcycle goes zoom like just
me oh my god it was like
talk about a [ __ ] ninth life i mean
it was so crazy
motorcycles are did dangerous i don't
care how good you are oh they look so
tasty though when i
when you're in traffic you know what i
was on my bike today going downhill i'm
cruising
winds in my face i got my tunes in you
know i'm like oh this is great
a motorcycle how good this
is i bet that's yeah 100 times it also
focuses your mind
it's so much more dangerous but it makes
sense why they do this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing